[Applause]
in delhi asia's youngest country
welcomes its new president
72 year old jose ramos horta is a
familiar face for most in east timor
also known as timoleste
it's the second time he's held the
presidency
the country gained independence 20 years
ago after more than two decades of
occupation by indonesia
it's often struggled with periods of
political instability
ramos horta has pledged to help resolve
the tensions between rival factions
to all parties both inside and outside
parliament i will continue to have
dialogue with everyone country is free
president ramos horta played a major
role in east timor's fight for
independence from indonesia
and has been an important political
figure ever since
after securing a landslide win in
elections in april he says he will focus
on strengthening regional
relations with the republic of indonesia
australia new zealand
and the south east asian countries
geographically close to timor-leste
must be at the top
of our
national agenda
istimo is the only country in southeast
asia that's not part of the association
of southeast asian nations or asean
indonesia has pledged to support ramos
horta's goal of becoming a member we try
our best
to convince other asean members on the
importance of timor less become part of
asean so we will continue to
convince other members
east timor is one of the poorest
countries in asia about 40 percent of
its population live below the poverty
line
everyone has high hopes that with
president ramos horta's connections we
can have cooperation with other
countries to develop to more or less
about 70 percent of people in east timor
are under 30 years old
it's a young country with a young
population
and while people haven't forgotten its
troubled past many are hoping for a
better future jessica washington al
jazeera